hey this is going to be a lesson for
some of our younger viewers some of our
younger viewers may be totally
unfamiliar with or not super familiar
with a woman named sarah palin who was
once the vice president she was almost
the vice president of the united states
were it not for voters choosing barack
obama over the late senator john mccain
in the 2008 presidential election
sarah palin
could have been the first female vice
president of the united states and she
would have been a horrible vice
president because she's an incompetent
clown
now she has resurfaced and i am going to
play an unbelievable video for you
she went on fox news to weigh in on the
aoc controversy the aoc controversy is
she
is for
i'm trying to even understand the
controversy she's four coveted
guidelines being followed and being
enacted
but she went to florida
um
and her partner didn't wear shoes i'm
sorry he wore flip-flops sitting outside
at a restaurant and then she got covered
and there's been all sorts of wacky
responses uh to to
her going to florida and getting coveted
one of the things that she said she
being aoc
that i think came off as a little bit
pompous to be completely honest is she
says the people the republicans
criticizing her want to date her and
this is just so funny sarah palin we've
covered her for so long because she ran
in you know 2008. sarah palin loses the
ability to communicate in english she
has these situations where she's like
visibly struggling to use language to
communicate anything of meaning and it
happened again and she weirdly says that
liberals want to pound
the idea of sex
into the minds of people see if you can
even follow what sarah palin is saying
here this is this is wild
it amazes me though her and other
liberals uh
socialists even their ability to what
socialist is she talking about reflect
from what the issues truly are and hear
her obsession with at least suggestions
of them
always gender and sex even it um
you know i truly believe that there are
enough americans who get it and
understand what her tactic is and that
is to deflect from what the real issues
are but uh yeah okay take this issue
though with her suggestion of dating and
if you're wondering what she's talking
about
everybody is this is how sarah palin
communicates it's completely unclear
what she's talking about and here we get
into pounding um and you know attraction
to someone and uh blaming her failures
on that uh that that obsession with sex
look how the liberals rachel uh want to
pound that into the public's head
that uh advertising who is attracted to
who what people do in their own the
privacy of their own bedrooms um all
those things that have to do with it's
really funny to hear sarah palin
who participated in an anti-gay campaign
in 2008 as vice president
on religious grounds now saying others
are talking about what people are doing
in their private bedrooms that's really
funny
privacy and sex the liberals not the
conservatives are the one who pound
pound pound after that and um obviously
it's a tactic so that she doesn't have
to be held accountable it sounds they
just want a pound pound pound about sex
and things in bedrooms and this we were
used to this sarah palin for a long time
complete word salads
and just as a little history lesson for
our younger viewers
i'm going to play a clip for you of
sarah palin this is from 2014 okay
this is how regularly incoherent she's
always been see if you can follow what
she's saying here
we believe
wait i thought fast food joints
don't you guys think that they're like
of the devil or something that's what
liberals you want to send those evil
employees who would dare work at a fast
food joint that you just don't believe
in thought you wanted to and i'll send
them to purgatory or something what so
they all go vegan
and uh
wages and picket lines i don't know
they're not often discussed in purgatory
are they i don't know why are you even
worried about fast food wages this has
not been edited or doctored in any way
this is this is the original thing she
said
well we believe
in america where minimum wage jobs
they're not lifetime gigs they're
stepping stone
okay so then there's me from from 2014.
uh that is the sarah palin that we have
been used to for a long time visibly
struggling to use the english language
and for our younger viewers you can go
to our youtube channel
and check out some of our older clips
uh it's probably time for her to
disappear for another eight years
because these appearances are not going
well
make sure that you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show we will
have these clips there if you have just
been listening today we'll take a quick
break and be right back i'm really
excited that uh one of our sponsors
today is helix sleep i sleep on a helix
mattress at home i absolutely love it
and that's why i reached out to them
about sponsoring the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video